my name is Emma I'm 15
Thomas Tosa I'm 25 years old chef
beverage age 72 I regularly use Facebook
Twitter and Instagram Facebook Instagram
and Twitter for about three hours a day
around two to four hours every day six
volunteers and a very modern challenge
I'm taking part and scroll free
September to increase my productivity I
want to see if I can give it up for a
month and what I can fill my time with
instead scroll free September is an
international campaign being led by the
Royal Society for public health
thousands of pledge to go cold turkey
and thousands more to reduce their
scrolling in a number of different ways
the branding is quirky the cause
extremely serious depression anxiety
lack of sleep cyberbullying fear of
missing out there's a whole load of
issues here
we need to do what we can to be able to
manage our social media better and
that's why now that's why we think it's
fairly urgent now and that's why the
issue is actually as important and for
young people maybe more important than
some of the other traditional public
health issues the campaign is the first
of its kind but follows the likes of
stalked Ober and DRI January both
initiatives have become annual events
helping people to pause their smoking
and drinking for this Facebook Instagram
snapchat Twitter and YouTube are all off
limits worldwide there are well over
five billion people signed up to the top
5 social media apps in many ways we're
hooked just take one example Instagram
every single day 95 million photos or
videos are posted to the platform for
many people quitting social media for a
month will be a major challenge but it's
hope by campaigners that will learn a
thing or two about their habits and how
they can affect our mental health and
well-being is social media taking over
your life the campaign comes at a time
when social media companies are under
increased scrutiny go
and users are questioning whether the
platforms are too big too addictive and
too destructive a parliamentary inquiry
is underway in the UK looking at the
effects of the apps on young people the
experiences of volunteers like ours over
the next four weeks will help address a
debate that's affecting everyone
Joe tidy Sky News